while waiting for deliveries of the
vaccine to arrive
bhutan was building an army twenty-two
thousand volunteers called desseps
who raised awareness carried out
screenings and quickly adapted to the
process of cold chain storage
as a frontliner i think it's my
responsibility to be vaccinated
and also because his majesty has done so
much for us so we feel it is our
responsibility as a citizen
when it was time to give everyone their
second shots the decepts got to work
and the results were astounding
vaccinations began on the 20th and
people have cooperated
a lot of people turned up on day one day
two day three and by day four
we had achieved our target in just seven
days bhutan administered nearly half a
million shots
and fully vaccinated 90 percent of its
adult population
for older people and others unable to
walk to vaccination sites
health officials went door to door i
think
we will be able to prevent the
transmission of the
coveted 19 which is which is our main
goal
and probably we expect that
hard immunity would be established in
the country and
now the country can open slowly
king jigme gesara jawangchak has spent
the last year hiking to remote villages
at times joined by prime minister lautai
shring who's a medical doctor
and if there's anything that i hope the
world can learn is that a country like
bhutan
with very few doctors very few nurses
but a really committed
king and leadership in the government
mobilizing society
it's not impossible to vaccinate the
whole country
bhutan is encouraging people to mix and
match vaccines
the first round of its national rollout
was donated by india the u.s chipped in
half a million doses of moderna for the
second
i think like the officials might have
researched on this
and without research they might not have
decided to do mix and match
so i trust them so that's why i decided
to take the modern vaccine it may be
small but the tiny kingdom has provided
a lesson on how to tackle a common
problem
at a faster pace than elsewhere andrew
chappelle
al jazeera